today looking to bounce back after a
very tough outing last time is blake
snell yeah two-thirds of an inning
against the buccos in pittsburgh he
takes them out for his fourth start
today the 28 year old has faced these
dodgers twice before of course once in
the world series last year games two and
six let's see what happens this
afternoon as mookie betts steps up to
home plate to lead this one off
this is tapped back towards the mound
look out could be trouble here tini
fires just in time to get the speedy
mookie bets carratini here's the key see
how he positioned himself around the
baseball and then picked it up
good throwing towards his glove side for
the strike to first base for the out one
out and brings up corey seeger
on the ground to machado he was on the
left side of the shift throw in time two
down
two outs and justin turner coming up
and that's strike three over the inside
corner blake snell picks up his first k
of the day as a one two three first
trevor bauer has been very hot like this
dodger pitching staff three or fewer
hits in all three of his starts
nine plus k's in all three of his starts
so we shall see what he's got for the
padres pro who has a couple walks in
this series weights on a payoff pitch
and swings and misses strike three
bauer opens his day with a strikeout his
30th of the year
95. you can almost see the spin rate as
this ball just maintains its altitude it
doesn't rise but to the hitter's eyes it
does
one out base is empty in the bottom of
the first
got him with the credit of the corner
two up and two down and a pair of trevor
bauer strikeouts
probably areas of trevor's mind that he
hasn't even explored yet but he is
definitely at a deeper level than most
pitchers in the big leagues whether it's
about training or pitch selection
part of the order coming up after one
two three first for blake snow it's will
smith
on a 3-2 smith wraps a line drive base
hit left center
a lead-off single for will smith here in
the second inning
taylor pushes the ball way back and gone
way good and two nothing
second home run for chris taylor against
blake snell
his third this season and they waste no
time taking the early lead
how is he looked great i mean so much
talk about justin turner but again
chris taylor kind of in the shadows of
one of the other stars on this team but
boy is he a star
of his own padres are shifting on the
right side on max muncie
and elevates to strikeout muncie second
strikeout for snell one down here in the
second inning 3-2 again to aj pollock
and that's strike three pollock thought
he had ball four gets the bad news from
phil cousy his back-to-back case for
blake snell three and all two down on
the second inning for sheldon noisy 2-2
swinging to miss fastball up out of the
zone and strike three three straight k's
for blake snell after the home run here
in the second inning that's a walk two
out jorge matteo coming up
there goes fam on a 2-2 that swung on
the miss 97 for strike three bowel with
his third k
one out one on and it brings up corey
seeger
that strike three gets the outside
corner with a good gas and that is
strikeout number five for blake snell
still has slowed it up here quite a bit
with runners at first and second and two
down payoff pitch to will smith
runners go and this is soft liner that
is caught by hosmer
dodgers two to nothing the o2 swung on
and missed strike three
the bower is very power like to this
point he is struck out four
profile hits it in the air
right field mookie bats
will put
[Music]
one and two and snell delivers swinging
a mass got a fastball past muncie that's
six strikeouts in three and two thirds
is exactly up to this point what blake
snell needs there's the fastball and
muncie goes down swinging padres trying
to avoid the sweep jake cronenworth
coming up to lead off against trevor
bauer so one two
and a fly ball to deep right field off
the bat at jake croninworth
very good
first home run of 2021 is something to
see for jake croninwood
you know what they say about the
breaking ball you hangy oh and he will
bang me there's the breaking ball oh
don't do it and jake croninworth says
come get a taste that's not a cheapy
folks
so two out machado the tying run at
second base and tommy fam coming up
got him
chased the hard cutter
trevor bauer with his fifth six
strikeouts today he is walk two only
allowed two hits
swinging a miss and it gets away from
karate briefly he's gotta throw him out
and he does seven strikeouts for snell
second time noisies down by way of the k
payoff pitch to bets
this one has got all kinds of spin on it
headed out to hosmer
throws in time
still covered
and they just get bets at first base so
one two three fifth
the 2-2
popped up left side
turner now fighting the wind eddie trips
over third base after making the play
safe he takes a header with a smile on
his face
so now he is the
[Music]
butt end of this joke
or should we say the face first
as you can see the humor hasn't started
kim pinch hitting this would be the
ninth pitch from trevor bauer in a 2-1
game in the fifth here it comes
strike three called bauer and the
dodgers will take it represents the
tying run two guard in the six so bauer
wants to get tatis the payoff pitch
got him swinging with a fast ball and
pounces his chest as he walks off
seventh strike out of the game
for trevor bauer brew star grader all is
about to make his season debut not just
against the padres but against manny
machado in a 2-1 game
through the left side into left field at
base hit for machado good start to the
bottom of the seventh inning eric cosmer
old for two today
machado at second base nobody out hosmer
with a liner that's fair kicks off the
box saints machado is coming around to
tie this game at two and it's hasbro
drives him in
eric hosmer has been the guy with
runners in scoring position who you feel
the most confident in
and we are tied at two two down and
it'll be left up to eric hosmer who tied
the game last inning hosmer back up the
middle into center field
coming around his profar throw goes to
third and the padres have got a 3-2 lead
out at third base is tatisse
wants him to check and they are going to
challenge padres challenging the out of
third base
uh looks like he's on the back yes it is
and
does he stay on the bag does he stay yes
he does
i got safe right there
he is safe and now the padre is an
opportunity to add to this three to two
lead
two in scoring position
vam down the left field line that is
into the corner
from third comes tatiks here comes
hasberg to second goes fam and it's
fantastic the padres take a 5-2 lead
grind it out tommy
change up gets it
you think his teammates are happy for
him friars lead by three mark valencia
the closer to the game trying to grab
this third game of the series they stand
as one
to the friar faithful at petco park in
san diego
taylor will pop it up
hosmer at first just back of the bag
it's over
padres win
ending at fantastic series this was fun
can't wait for more
padres are hungry for more three-ninth
inning
for mark malanson as the padres down the
dodgers in game three
five to two